I've got something very important to tell you.
Something we can't keep quiet any longer.
We felt it was time the people knew.
Nike Air is actually the air of our very best athletes.
We've been collecting athletes' air for over 30 years now.
Come with me.
Welcome to the Air Collection Unit.
This is where we collect the air from our athletes to put it in the shoe.
Hey, Troy!
Hey, Carl!
Hey!
How's she doing?
Oh! I tell you, these young kids are something else.
Oh, come on! Don't be so humble.
You're still delivering great triple A air.
Come on, B-Roy!
Dude!
Time to give air.
Alright!
Hey, Paula! All yours?
Yup, all mine.
Girl power!
Okay, guys! We're about to meet Maria Sharapova.
Don't be weird.
You simply walk up and you say, "Hi, Maria! You're beautiful."
No, don't say that!
Hey, P-Rod!
Hi, Maria!
Was that a "Switch"?
Yeah.
Hey, Paulie!
Easy, Sharpie.
They tell me my air is really special.
It's special, alright.
It's an extra step for us.
I had to develop a grunt removal system.
Before...
...and after.
So, why tell you all of this now?
We just couldn't keep it under wraps anymore.
Our athletes are becoming stronger.
Their air is getting stronger.
Help!
It's great that even now, my air is being used by Nike to help kids perform better.
I work really hard to put my air into these shoes.
So if you could please take good care of them.
Technically, we collect your air in canisters and then we put it in the shoes.
I know that.
Of course, you know that.
Well, there you have it.
Nike Air is actually the air of our very best athletes.
Please treat with caution.